[Music]
my name is Vadim I work at data dock as
a data engineer and today I'm going to
be talking about using apache spark for
brass and trillions of records everyday
so a little bit information about data
doc we are a monitoring service for
things like databases web servers
cloud-based tools or communication tools
we have over 200 integrations and we can
accept any custom metric we also provide
application performance monitoring and
you can set up alerts on top of those
metrics and we keep data for over 18
months with a one-second resolution and
I'm going to be talking about the
service that produces this historical
data but no worries everything that I'm
going to be talking about can be applied
to any apache spark based job so the
initial setup that we were targeting we
use AWS EMR we wanted to use 100 to 200
r3 to flourish notes
those are pretty beefy with 244 gigs of
ram we were trying to use spot instances
as they are cheaper roughly five times
the on demand notes and we were using
spark 1.6 in your own classroom oh and
we use Scala and our GD a PA and quickly
we learned that actually it's only 240
gigs because of then and here's some
other settings that we used as you can
see the most important thing as
everybody knows in Java is garbage
collection settings oh I'm just kidding
we tried to put driver and executor on
the same node manager so we could
utilize resources at for and how big is
a trillion trillion a is a roughly 500
times bigger than maximum value of
integer so and in Java arrays a limited
at they cannot hold more than two
billion elements so it was natural for
us that we're going to hit our favorite
error out of memory right so what people
do when they hit the out of memory in
SPARC they Google and they get 2.5
million results and they realize ok it's
probably related to Java 77 million
results and then they start tweaking and
complaining about Java and stuff stuff
like that
and there are different types of out of
memory the first one is related to heap
size second is about garbage third is
something is using off heap memory
fourth is your your non manager is
killing your container because it
promised to not go beyond certain water
mark but it went and not manager killed
it and fifth is simply your operating
system doesn't have more memory and
killed it so we tried the first thing
that we learned is that the driver must
arrive because it's a single point of
failure so we increased memory and now
the driver doesn't run alongside
executors so they don't fight for
resources but our job was still failing
and how do people fix their jobs when
they fail on out of memory this is a
image of spark fine tuning using Sparky
I so you have three gauges garbage
collection pick executors memory usage
and input records and then you have a
lot of knobs to tune it executors memory
over had split size I cough threats you
name it and you basically try to turn
them and try to see if your job works so
you need some observability monitoring
we were we stumbled upon this project
from Etsy called SD JVM profiler it's
easy to add it to your executors and you
start getting metrics so we submit
metrics to data dot and you can see how
much heap we use so the Purple Line is
our max X Max and the orange line is how
much memory we use we also edit events
so the red bars represent when our
stages start to finish so we can kind of
see what is actually using a lot of
memory and we also track garbage
collection so we were fine on garbage
collection and by using all of this we
were able to solve some of our out of
memories and everything was fine but we
were still getting errors like this and
noticed something
it's nao and forget and it turns out the
use of
keep memory and there are also multiple
things that use of you so there is
direct allocated buffers like Burkett
message back
there's Java native interface it's
mostly used for compression libraries
like GZ sleep lz4 and there is unsaved
direct memory access that is used in
some of spark and Hadoop packages and
how we measure all of them we cannot
measure them but we can actually check
how much memory our process is using so
there's a such thing as rocket fest that
you can query so you basically use the
process ID and get the information and
the metric that you are looking at more
interested in is resident cell size and
there's still problem how we submit this
metric how we get it automatically
without going to each node and
coordinate and I present you our
solution so basically it's a Java agent
but we get memory we ask the operating
system about how much memory my JVM
process is using and then submitted and
we started getting the real process
memory usage so you can see we use
hundred twenty gigs but the heap used is
about 70 so 50 gigabytes is spent on
some of hip so by doing that you can
actually see based on what stage is
currently running you can kind of
predict and understand what is actually
using in your of heap memory and we also
submit data for each container so when
your container fails on out of memory
you can check what it was doing and what
was it was a memory usage before that so
you can kind of understand what exactly
is using memory and by doing that we
were able to solve all out of memory
almost but the job was still slow in
some parts and we didn't know where it's
low so we added up sorry the lessons
that we learned give more resources that
you think you would need because it's
easier your first goal is to make sure
that your job actually works and that
once it works you can scale it down
merger memory usage of each executor to
see who is using maybe there are skewed
parts maybe something else keep an eye
on your garbage collection metrics to
make sure that you don't produce a lot
of Java objects and we started measuring
in slow parts so here you can see we
just added some timer and we submit it
as a cumulative so we get what's the
maximum time of your map function and
what is the total time and we also watch
this cute part so in this case we group
by key and we get values for the key and
we check what it was the size of the all
values and if it's if it goes beyond a
certain threshold we just don't process
it but we still log in and we can still
process it some separate in a separate
way this way you make sure that your job
doesn't fail and if there's a huge key
you can process it separate or don't
process it at all and we also keep track
of what keys have a lot of values and
you don't need to report these metrics
for all the keys because you have for
example a billion kiss you there's a lot
of polls you can report just max time or
max number of values for each of the
partitions ones with each task ends and
we also collect executor metrics so here
you see input records processed by a
single executor per second and you can
see that the job gets faster or slower
in some parts and just by doing that you
can identify the slowest parts of your
job or the fastest and the lessons we
learned so murder slowest parts of your
job like I said murder what parts of
your job are skewed and what keys have
skews and keep track of how much CPU is
actually spent because a lot of people
when they compare how fast their spur
jobs became the
look at the world clock time which is
not entirely correct and have some
alerting on metrics so all the metrics
that we collect like skewed parts or
slow parts we also have alerts on top of
them so we get alerts when our job gets
lower or somebody is I'm offending keys
found and so on so you can be proactive
before your jump your job fails so we
were using spot instances and everything
was fine until as you can see on the
graph in April of this part market
started collapsing and you can see that
it was until August and that means that
our cluster was constantly dying and the
job wasn't progressing so to mitigate
this issue we broke the job into smaller
survivable pieces but because of that
our job overall became slower because we
have we had to wait for the previous job
to finish before starting a new one so
we enable dynamic allocation and we
started submitting these small jobs in
parallel and because of that we had to
disable caching because when your
executor holds some data it cannot go
and leave the job board and join the
other job instead we use checkpoint it
writes data to HDFS so the executor can
quit the job and other executors can
still to get data from HDFS and it
helped dynamic allocation like I said
and losing multiple executors doesn't
result in losing your job recomputing a
lot of partitions because your data is
on the HDFS but we open a box of Pandora
called external shuffle service so when
your executor is using dynamic
allocation it writes partitions on the
instance for example if you get a one
wrote partitions 1 2 3 4 and then it
tells the driver that I have no more
work to do and the driver tells the
executor that you can leave the job and
then executors will take data from the
instance directly by
talking to external shuffled service but
what happens if the instance dies
unfortunately a driver doesn't know that
the instance is gone
and it tells that the second executor
that partitions still leave on that
instance executor 2 tries to communicate
with the external travel service but
gets an exception
tells the driver that there's no
partition the driver says okay let's
recomputed and your job is going to
recompute all the partitions that led to
that partition ok first partition was
recomputed third executor does the same
recomputes but what if your job has ten
thousand partitions it will take ages to
recompute everything because the driver
doesn't flush like it doesn't clear it
doesn't remove all partitions because it
still thinks that if the instance is
still there it still has files so let's
try to get files from that instance so
these are some issues related to
external shuffle service problem and
unfortunately there are a lot more fetch
failures that we observe and this is the
umbrella ticket about optimizing the
fetch failures so this is our solution
to that this problem was to stop using
spot instances so we started using
on-demand instances but unfortunately
there is still a possibility to lose one
instance store in especially in our case
when we get run like 200 instance
instances it's not a rare event to lose
just one and then because of external
shuffle service your job just goes
forever so keep an eye on failed tests
failed test tasks so you would know when
your job is actually breaking as you can
see on this graph as soon as market
started misbehaving we started getting
more and more available tasks and once
the market stabilized we actually switch
to on demand notes the number dropped
but still we get sporadic
failed tasks want the job and doesn't
move em so keep keep an eye on that so
the lessons keep all logs so when our
raffle service was misbehaving it was
difficult to see what was what was going
on so we had to go through all logs and
see who was talking to who what kind of
errors they were getting and what was
the stage actually and so on spark isn't
super resilient even when one node dies
that's what we learned about spark
unfortunately and we just have to
monitor the number of failed task stages
number of lost nodes so be proactive
about the page feathers everything was
fine
everything was moving great until it
wasn't
so here we join two three arteries and
all joints in our tapi done through coal
group so basically it gets data for the
same key and puts your gives you
iterators and in our case we had to have
one-to-one join but just out of being
cautious and being safe just edit some
checks that we actually get just one
element and it was more for ourselves if
we just somebody changed the code and
the test should fail here but we were
running our job and one day it fired
here that the key received wasn't one
record and it should never never happen
and as you can see we also have to set
so we only care about if we get multiple
different values and this situation
should never happen but it happened so
what was the problem turns out when one
executor tries to query get data from
the other executors it can sometime get
fetch failure and it will tell the
driver that I need to read to recompute
that partition and the partition gets
recomputed but the instance that produce
fetch failed actually still running it
comes
sensitive partition and now you get two
values for the same key and in our case
it was because we were sorting our tuple
just by the first field so as you can
see we have one ten one one
but if results come differently upon
recomputing you get different output and
the solution was simple just to sort
everything by all fields the lessons
that we learn trust by put extra checks
and log everything we were trusting
sparked that it would not it would
recompute everything it would just drop
the partitions that were we computing
right add extra and so make sure that
even when your framework promises you
that everything will be all right just
to make sure make sure that upon we
computing you still produce the same
result even when you we are sure that
everything will be fine and file the job
as soon as possible when some unexpected
behavior is observed but maybe you still
can overcome these unexpected behavior
so in our case we were even when we got
multiple values we were only we really
only cared if we get multiple different
results so our job would run even if we
so our job still runs even when we get
multiple same results upon we compete
because we made sure that upon we
competing of partitions we produce
always the same result and have retries
from the pipeline scheduled level
because this job is not going to survive
but upon every try it can actually
survive because there will be no lost or
like later Ivan partitions so we left
our job running for a month and to do
test start pushing more more and more
data and we got all these five issues
and the last one we actually repair our
cells and some of those issues were
fixed in spark too
so we migrated easily to spark to solve
this problem and the lessons from this
short chapter is check the bug tracker
periodically to see what a new issues
were added or what has been solved
subscribe to mailing list to see what
issues people my head that you are going
to hit more likely and participate in
discussing issues if you don't
understand what what's going on
just check and ask and in conclusion I
want to repeat log everything including
drivers exodus non-manager garbage
collection everything it will in case of
a failure it will you will have all the
information needed to see what exactly
what's happening measure everything you
might have to measure memory you have to
merge the garbage collection executor
CPU file task stages slow parts cute
parts everything measure everything
trust but be ready like we put a lot of
trust in how Apache spark works and
Apache spark promises that it's super
resilient but sometimes it's not and we
hit those problems especially when you
work at large scale and don't try to run
one huge job always breaks a your job
into smaller survivable pieces because
one huge job the transport and ours has
a high chance of failing and you still
in you going upon failure you have to
retry it and it is again going to run
for 10 hours instead of just breaking in
10 jobs maybe if you can and those those
smaller jobs will have higher chance of
surviving and this is pretty much all I
have if you want to work with us on
spark of career elasticsearch or
something else come to our booth or
check our website and if you have any
questions here's my Twitter handle and
my personal and working mail
[Applause]
hi so you mentioned Sparkle agency being
kind of a constant right
especially run you know memory
specifically so can you reflect a bit on
one using small versus using the dupe in
this potential case using Hadoop for
example yeah yeah it is possible but
Hadoop after each stage finishes you
write to HDFS right
so in that case yeah the job would be
would definitely survive better but it
will be slower because in SPARC you can
actually keep some memory as some data
in memory on executors directly and you
don't have this condition where you have
to wait until your job finishes I mean
sorry until you don't have to write to
HDFS right which adds up like on
serializing writing to HDFS and so on so
there are like different trade-offs the
other the other solution that I heard of
is some companies run spark break the
job into two different jobs which so for
example one runs as a spark job and then
you go into some and then you write it
the second job in hadoop mapreduce
because it survives better right so you
kind of use both techniques hey question
you spoke about measuring skew data
measuring key skew could you could you
speak a little bit about any sort of
strategies you have developed or general
strategies for actually handling case Q
so in our case we we try to make sure
that we don't have a lot of parts where
we have skews by so we have few joints
and the joints are so for example in our
case we had joints on two columns but we
rewrote they join in to use three
columns and we had to add extra
so for each record from the smaller
table we had to add additional record
with third key so all our joints work on
that small level and we know for sure
that that small level doesn't have more
than 10,000 elements but we still have
SKUs in other parts and the only
solution that we come up with we
unfortunately couldn't use like salting
on something else we basically have to
start processing once we hit this
threshold so for example 100 million
points that's a lot and we don't press
that or we can process separately and we
still get the metrics what keys are
skewed so we still see them in our
interface so we we we can reach out to
customers or reach out to whoever
submitted this key with a lot of values
and say them that actually we haven't
processed you in a cluster in such large
size do you are till you currently using
EMR and do you currently experience any
kind of s3 eventual consistency okay I
see what you're saying we still use AWS
EMR because it not only provides for
just cluster it also locks a lot of data
so for example it locks all the
processes that were running every 15
minutes all the disk space usage and so
on so used in it it saves all the logs
from from yarn to s3 so you can later
analyze them and figure out what was
going on if in case of a failure and
recently they also added a feature for
spa they automatically feed SPARC lock
UI logs so you can actually see in AWS
EMR interface how it was doing so yes
that's the reason why we use in mark and
as the consistency issues we don't have
because in our case we we don't actually
use Hadoop output writers we wrote our
own writers because we we had to
right files twice in different files but
we didn't want to split the job into two
jobs so we actually have map function
that writes data to the s3 and we know
for sure that there's like just limited
amount of data we don't go beyond 15
megabytes so and we after we wrote we
check that we actually wrote the wiki so
we don't we don't have any eventual
consistency problems yeah this might be
a bit off topic but the JVM profiler
that you guys wrote is that does that
only write to date a dog or do you have
like a we actually we just poured the
add CSS DGM profiler and it writes to a
necessity back-end you can hook it up to
influx DB or anything but the features
that might be specific to data log is
the container IDs and stuff like that
because I'm not sure if study supports
tags for example
[Music]